hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
on arrow they finally introduced in this
al Ghul and filled in a bunch of
backstory for several different
characters bonus shout out to Doctor Who
fans because Alex Kingston was back
spoilers in addition to my review I have
a ton of air news about the rest of the
season and news about the flash spin-off
show since there's so much I'm just
gonna put all that flash stuff in a
separate video be sure to subscribe to
get it
I'm gonna post it tomorrow whenever I
post my Q&A video for arrow careful for
spoilers from tonight's episode but it
was amazing it was kind of like a
CrossFit video mixed with the drama
let's start with top five moments of
number five Moira versus brother blood
in an episode all about venom it seemed
like Moira was the most dangerous snake
their big confrontation came right after
a scene where Oliver and Felicity were
talking all about fangs throughout the
episode I noticed that Moira had this
Lionel Luthor look on her face if he
didn't watch Smallville he was like the
nicest bad guy in the world it's easy to
understand why Merlin would have been
someone she was attracted to the really
good thing about her taking on brother
blood is that now he has to deal with
her and team arrow at the same time
pending anything that Slade does to
quote/unquote fix it number four
Felicity tells Oliver all about Thea
this was actually a meta moment that
Stephen Amell had been teasing he said
that Felicity would get some backstory
in this episode and when she explained
Thea to Oliver she talked all about her
father leaving and filled in some really
critical information about her character
I have to say that Emily bet is awesome
mostly when she and Stephen Amell
inertness scene together
Oliver's reaction was really good too if
he didn't catch it whenever he went up
to the podium that Red Queen for mayor
it was a huge shout out to the comic
books the Green Arrow actually became
mayor of the city for a while I really
like the way arrow plays on our
expectations I keep expecting Merlyn to
appear in the background every time they
say his name number three the canary and
mrs. Shipp they kind of teased us with
that line the child of Ra's al Ghul
awaits your return I did think that it
might have been a sexual relationship
but they wasted no time in answering
that question you can think of Nyssa as
the Oliver of that relationship and
Sarah as felicity be sure to give the
arrow riders a big high-five for
including some real diversity on the
show in the DC Universe lesbian and
bisexual characters aren't really a new
thing but it's not something that
male-driven comic book TV shows do very
often I thought it was really
interesting when Nyssa released Sarah
from the leak I thought that only Rachel
goal could do that
and usually he did it just by chopping
people in half number two slate finally
steps into the ring Manu Bennett has
been such an awesome post-credits
character in this season it's almost
like all of his big scenes happen in the
last three minutes of every episode his
comment I'll take care of it makes it
sound like he's actually finally going
to confront team arrow as Deathstroke
it's like brother blood is tagging out
and Slade is tagging in I do feel like
he's going to wait to reveal himself to
Oliver until after he fights them as
Deathstroke it's a classic villain
reveal where the heroes go I wonder who
this mystery assassin is which leads to
you know oh
it's that guy stabbed in the eye six
years ago and left for dead and my
number one moment the Emerald Archer
versus the heir to the demon best fight
of the season hands down as I say we're
trying to see who could out arrow each
other I guess
archery is a really big deal in the
league first there's Merlin Ben Oliver
now Nyssa even the canary was a dead
shot with Oliver's bow I really like
Katrina law as Nyssa in the episodes
hopefully she'll come back in the future
but that's unconformity
if Oliver vs Nyssa was the best fight
then the car chase was the best stunt if
he didn't catch it there was actually a
shout-out to the canary cry at the end
whenever she screamed let me know what
your favorite moment from the episode
was you know was it the big fight scene
was it seeing Miss al Ghul for the first
time was it seeing Nyssa and the canary
I actually saw a hashtag on Twitter that
said sisse
I actually kind of broke my favorites
apart a little bit first you know I love
the fight scene but the best character
moment was actually Oliver and Felicity
as expected we absolutely had to give
Cady lots of shout out for giving
Stephen Amell a run for his money on
those salmon ladders overall I loved the
episode I actually gave it an 8 just
because it gave us so much story and
still had some amazing action scenes and
made us cry a little bit I didn't cry
but every time Felicity cries I almost
want to cry just because her character
is so sympathetic
high-fives demo a bet for making
everyone cry I'm still not digging
laurels arc sassy sisters was not fun to
watch
I like watching evil characters be evil
like Slade getting ready to kick
someone's ass but I can't stand watching
good characters just be awful to each
other the episode did an awesome job of
drawing me into the story and surprising
me I genuinely believe Sara was gonna
kill herself and jumpstart the Laurel
Black Canary arc but then remembered all
the birds of prey talk the writers were
doing last week so time for big air news
for the rest of the season careful for
spoilers if you don't want to know
anything about what's coming
starting where we're at right now Sarah
is back for good and she's part of the
arrow cave it's definitely starting to
get crowded with Roy in there it's gonna
be like a Salmon Ladder party with those
three starting next week though with
episode 14 and extending through episode
18 it's gonna be like a villain arc they
actually used the villains United comic
book reference to describe it it
includes a public appearance from
Deathstroke a real-deal Suicide Squad
and the birds of prey 16 is going to be
the Suicide Squad episode and 17 will be
the birds of prey episode so you can see
as the villains start to pile up on team
arrow a group of heroes like the birds
of prey jump in to help them out so like
I said in related news I'm doing that
separate flash video tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'm also going to be posting my next Q&A
video tomorrow too so ask me any
questions you want about the flash or
what just happened in this episode right
now click here to get that flash video
I'll have the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here to get last
week's arrow episode thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you